[la musique]
pourquoi est-elle dans le tapis la question est qui je
j'entends tout le temps
dans le tapis cette voiture était une par une
raison simple que je voulais faire
quelque chose de nouveau que personne d'autre n'a fait
J'ai longtemps réfléchi, pour être honnête, parce que
beaucoup de Zhiguli avaient déjà des idées à traiter
cabriolets gainés personne avec une pelouse que
une telle chose, mais pour une raison quelconque, les tapis
personne n'a pensé
[la musique]
jour une tempête d'émotions au premier regard des gens
les gens cool comprennent encore mieux
parce que cette voiture n'est pas seulement là
films à l'œil, pas ce qui est réel
les tapis
[la musique]